Siemens розриває угоди з російськими компаніями через свої турбіни в Криму - всупереч санкцій ЄС.
Зокрема, німецький концерн вийде зі спільного з росіянами підприємства "Інтеравтоматика"
та призупинить ліцензійні угоди з компаніями з РФ щодо поставок обладнання для електростанцій.
Це урок для західних компаній і сигнал бізнесу подумати ще раз, чи співпрацювати з Росією, вважають у Європарламенті.
Особливо обладнання і технології, які надходитимуть в енергосектор, транспортну галузь -
все це перевірятиметься не лише за контрактом, а на місці, де це обладнання має встановлюватись у РФ.
Інакше нас знову і знову дуритимуть російські партнери.
Прес-секретар президента Росії відмовився коментувати рішення Сіменс. А представники таких
російських держкомпаній як "Росатом" і "Інтер РАО", заявили, що обмеження з боку німецького виробника їх не зачеплять.
За даними агенції Reuters, в російському енергетичному секторі вже шукають спеціалістів, які мають досвід запуску турбін Siemens.
Однак без спеціалістів самого концерну ще німецькі турбіни досі ніколи не запускали. В Росії на електростанціях зараз працюють 18 таких турбін.
Нових санкцій за доставку турбін в Крим і порушення росіянами угод Євросоюз не запроваджуватиме.
В Брюсселі вважають, що діючі санкції й так доволі суттєві. Натомість на вже укладені контракти, найімовірніше, чекатиме ретельна перевірка.
Довіри не було, а тепер і поготів. Siemens отримав достовірну інформацію,
що всі чотири турбіни, які влітку 2016 року він надав для проекту на Тамані у південній Росії, були модифіковані на місці та протиправно,
з порушенням контракту, переправлені до Криму", - йдеться у заяві німецького концерну.
Siemens пропонує викупити у росіян своє ж обладнання і анулювати початковий контракт.
Ціна чотирьох турбін - понад 166  мільйонів евро.